CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was president
george w bush's homeland security and
counterterrorism advisor and she joins
us at the table you know that interview
last night scott belly's interview had
several I thought jaw-dropping moments
that was certainly one of them you know
rod Rosen Stein I do we work together at
the Justice Department does it surprise
you to hear that he might have been
considering reaching out to James Comey
about this does that sound like someone
you know you know it's surprising given
the circumstances but I think we know
for sure Rosen Stein was wrote that memo
reluctantly Comey had been a career
official in the Justice Department long
before he was FBI director and so as it
was Rosenstein right and so I think that
their long history and a shared history
working in the Justice Department
explains why he might have wanted to do
it well friend how knowing the facts
that Andrew McCabe had in front of him
how justified was he in launching two
FBI investigations into the President of
the United States so Anthony having done
this when I was in the Justice
Department you know the FBI brings in a
case and they must have a legal
predicate and McCabe was very careful
last night he used the word predicate
and he laid out the facts right he
relied on the the president asked him to
shut down the Michael Flynn
investigation he's meeting with the
Russians he went through it and we can
argue whether or not it was enough but
he'd certainly laid out the predicate to
open to justifiably open up these cases
it doesn't mean that the president was
guilty of collusion right but it's just
an investigation Fran as mccabe laid out
this story for the first time in full or
an earful were there parts of the
conversation parts of his explanation
that gave you pause yeah i mean look
let's be clear we here at CBS offered
him the opportunity when his first fire
to come on air he's doing he's promoting
a book right now first second so do you
doubt what are you saying you think this
is all about promoting a book well I no
I don't think it's all about promoting a
book but I think we have to be honest
that we ought to be skeptical about
parts of this right he has been accused
of lying not once or twice but three
times did inspector general and the 25th
amendment let's let's talk about that
for a second that whole conversation
with McCain he doesn't remember how it
came up
this is not a conversation you would
have ever had before so he doesn't
remember how it came up he remembers
that Rosenstein in this conversation is
counting votes but when Scott asks him
he doesn't remember how each cabinet
member was voting or what Rosenstein
said about that and so I think we ought
to be a little bit scared believe he
would have offered to wear a wire
I don't and not based on my own
interactions with rod Rosenstein I find
it hard to believe now listen in this
environment down in Washington
everything yes a little bit different
was the FBI in chaos well I think that's
a better term I do think that's a fair
term I will say we should just to be
clear I was down there in this couple of
days right because I was invited down to
the Justice Department with my
Rosenstein to be interviewed for the FBI
director job and he seemed himself he
was calm he was I mean he's a real
lawyers lawyer and so I I don't imagine
Rosenstein you know hair on fire
friend thank you very much always a
pleasure to have you here